can the government restrict people's
ability to spend money on speech here
are the full rules of free speech and
money rule 1 generally your right to
speak includes the right to spend money
to speak the government can limit for
instance a newspapers budget even if it
thinks newspapers have too much
influence over elections and politicians
the government can't stop the National
Rifle Association or the Sierra Club
from spending money to praise the
candidates they like and it can't limit
what other Americans spend either
sometimes people frame the question as
is money speech but that's not right
here's an analogy the sixth amendment
protects criminal defendants right to
hire a lawyer say the government said
you can hire any lawyer you like but you
can't pay them more than a thousand
dollars it would be unfair the theory
goes for rich people to hire better
lawyers than poor people can that
restriction would violate the sixth
amendment but not because money is a
lawyer but because the right to a lawyer
includes the right to spend money on a
lawyer the same is true for most other
rights the Supreme Court has held that
people have a right to send their
children to private school if the
government were to say you can't spend
more than a thousand a year on private
schooling that would violate the right
to educate your children but again not
because money is an education but
because the right to educate your
children includes the right to spend
money on schooling Justice Breyer who's
actually open to substantial
restrictions on spending money for
speech but this well a decision to
contribute money to a campaign as a
matter of First Amendment concern not
because money is speech it is not but
because it enables speech so
restrictions on spending money to speak
the Supreme Court has held are
restrictions on speech and are thus
generally unconstitutional rule 2 the
government can limit direct
contributions to candidates as opposed
to just spending money to speak about
candidates in 1976 for instance the
Supreme Court upheld a capital
contributions to federal candidates the
court also upheld even lower caps as low
as $250 for state and local candidates
part of the reasoning behind that
conclusion is that contribution
restrictions limit speech less than
expenditure restrictions precisely
because of restrictions on contributions
to candidates still leave people free to
say whatever they like independently of
the candidate rule 3 the government may
also bar nonprofit organizations from
spending tax deductible contributions on
political campaigning the charitable tax
deduction is viewed as a sort of subsidy
say you're in the 40 percent tax bracket
if you give $1,000 to a charity you save
$400
and taxes that contribution is thus
equivalent to you're paying $600 non
tax-exempt to the charity and the
government forking over $400 based on
this subsidy theory the Supreme Court
has held that the government may attach
conditions to this tax deduction one
such condition is that groups that
collect accident will money aren't
supposed to use it to endorse or oppose
political candidates if they want to
engage in such speech that can just with
money they get without the tax exemption
that's why many groups such as the ACLU
the NRA the Sierra Club actually have
two related groups a so-called 501 C 3
group that collects tax-deductible
donations and can't use them for
political campaigning and a 501 C 4
group that collects non-tax deductible
donations that it can use for politics
rule for the government may completely
bar people who aren't citizens or lawful
permanent residents from spending money
to advocate for or against candidates
though non-citizens present in the US
generally have broad First Amendment
rights the federal court held that these
rights can be limited when it comes to
spending even small sums of money
related to elections the Supreme Court
upheld that decision though the justices
didn't issue a written opinion so to sum
up your right to speak like most of your
other rights includes the right to spend
money to speak contributions given to
candidates can be restricted those
speech said independently of the
candidates is protected the government
can insist the tax deductible
contributions can't be used to support
or oppose candidates so nonprofits are
free to politic for candidates using non
tax-deductible donations the rule is
different for non-citizens at least
those who aren't lawful permanent
residents they can be barred from
spending money to support or oppose
candidates this is not legal advice if
this were legal advice it would be
followed by a bill please use
responsibly written by Eugene Bullock
who is an actual real-life First
Amendment law professor at UCLA i'm
eugene Baalak and i approve this message
you